so uh my first question go ahead would
you consider yourself red pill never in
a million never why in a million years
why um I think to me first and foremost
I think I don't subscribe to any
man-made ideology okay because I think a
lot of these ideologies put you in a box
um so I do subscribe to religion and
people can argue with us man-made or not
um that's gonna be great conversation
great debate you get a guy like Sam
Harris and Jordan Peterson had a great
debate about that um but in regards to
man-made ideologies I don't really
subscribe to them as much and I don't
like to identify myself with something
that somebody else has conjured up with
their own personal opinion and so I
think in regards to the red pill is a
very interesting space a lot of
interesting characters there and I think
the the biggest challenge to me is the
the phrase that they use is that we're
all we're doing is trying to share the
truth about fill in the blank right and
to me it's very very very arrogant as a
human being to say I myself am the
orator of the truth I I know the truth
my studies are the accurate studies my
ideas and accurate ideas I am the only
individual who knows these things and so
to me that ideology seems very cult-like
in my opinion
um if you believe in them they give you
uh praise words like oh yo you're red
pilled you're an alpha male right and if
you disagree with them to give you the
the curse words right you are blue pill
you are a Beta male right are you
talking about like the comment section
I'm just talking about this the idea of
the philosophy right okay so the people
who subscribe to their worldview are red
pill individuals right their minds have
been opened up to the truth right and
people disagree with their ideas are
considered blue pill right you have
rejected the truth I.E The Matrix right
the guy in the major he said I want to
go back in the machine even though I
know it I want to go back in the machine
so to me that seems very cult to like in
regards to the ideology and so there's a
lot of different reasons why I don't
subscribe to it but those are the few
things I just I just cannot hold myself
to an ideology that a certain individual
or individuals are communicating without
understanding the of those ideas yeah
because they would say it's a praxeology
not an ideology yeah it's very easy to
use words like that but then then you
break down what does that mean yeah so
my question to you is like what
specifically do you disagree with great
question so when people say things like
okay we're not an ideology we're
practicality right you have to ask
yourself are you teaching any ideas
uh-huh like is there any principles that
your belief system is teaching because
every human being's belief system
teaches teaches and ideas right and so
for me when I see that there are certain
ideas and premises that are being taught
therefore you cannot simply say we are
we are not an ideology there is no
ideals that represent the things that we
believe and so an example of what are
some of the things to disagree with I
think I primarily disagree with a lot of
times the descriptions of marriage okay
and just how they analyze and describe
marriage in today's world I think I just
I disagree with the analysis of a male
female nature I think if you were to
read a book like the evolution of Desire
by Dr David Buss he's a worldly and
expert on a human evolutionary
psychology in regards to mating and he's
fantastic bus School of Psychology is
amazing and you actually read a person
who's like a world-renowned expert on
this topic and you hear about all the
nuance and I love Dr Buss because Dr
Buss understands the nuance and the
cross-cultural studies and in the so
much data and you were to read some of
the more red pill
um you know Doctrine doctrinal books
you'll be like wow like it's you it's
literally like reading Dr Seuss and
reading something like Hamlet it's like
it's like night and day difference and
so to me I think I I I acknowledge that
a lot of their ideas are truthful like
any ideology right or whatever the heck
where they're using nowadays to convince
you but that's not an ideology yes those
things are there's truthfulness in it
but there's a whole lot of lies and a
whole lot of information that is not
statistically accurate and that's why
I've always recommended people to to
read books like the evolution of design
by Dr David Buss and then simply then
read whatever red pill literature that
you want and juxtapose those two ideas
and be and you'd be extremely astonished
to the differences well it's just
because everything you're saying is very
broad yeah so you even said like their
teachings on marriage because like from
my my understanding of red pill is that
they're they're not anti-marriage or
pro-marriage they're anti-marriage as it
is today and the way the laws are today
and do you disagree with that so I'm
gonna give you an example okay and I'm
excited because I'm really excited about
the way you the way you're processing
this yeah so let's go into mayor so
here's a here's a fundamental challenge
okay so red pill is very broad okay very
broad right really I don't I don't think
so actually you don't think so no so do
you do you think a person like alpha
male strategies teaches the same exact
ideas as coach Greg Adams
um I know more about alpha male
strategies than coach Greg Adams I
haven't watched a lot of Coach Greg okay
uh AMS he's like the [__] these hoes is
to sleep yeah but he's a vault that's
old school I don't know I just if a guy
tells me he watches AMS I'm like I gotta
run yeah but but even to that point
right so you're like I gotta run yeah
yeah so so there's there's a lot of then
there's you know there's individuals
like Steph is Cole I'm not sure if Steph
is Cole still called himself red pill
but he had to step his cold guys right a
lot a lot different than coach red pill
okay a lot different
um okay so so what I'm what I'm what I'm
articulating is that that within the red
pill umbrella yeah there's a diversity
of individuals yeah there's far right
this and there's guys a little bit more
balance so what usually happens when
we're having this conversation which
will require so much nuance and I'm glad
we're able to dive into it is that when
you're describing the red pill what
people want to do is one of two things
you either want to steal men them or you
want to straw man them the argument that
you're probably feeling like and some
people may feel like is that straw man
them right you pick the worst ideas of
red pill the worst content creators and
then you define the red pill as that but
then on the flip side is a steel man
where you find some of their best
brightest ideas ignore all the
negativity nonsense ideas and Define
that as a red pill now I mean to me it's
like there's a base set of ideas and
people have different ideas of what to
do who defines a base set of ideas
um I would say that I think that's
mostly whose defines the base I would
say Rolo tomasi I think he seems to be
like leading that like today but before
it seems like it was Patrice O'Neal
possibly do you think Patrice O'Neal was
was no I I think a lot of like
um it seems like a lot of ideas derived
from him but it seems like it it goes
around Rolo tomasi that's how it seems
like so the interesting part of the
conversation going back to the red pill
conversation yeah because I know you
want to talk about this is that there is
no single Source there's no doctrinal
Source there's a lot of individuals
who've written their books and shared
their ideas as red pill and depending on
on where what school of thought you're
in a lot of individuals will say well
that's not red pill for me he's not red
pill for me maybe in your world he's red
pill for you and some people red pill
for them might be coached Berg Adams
people right people for them might be
fresh and fit people red pill for that
might be AMS to be red pill for that
might be coach for them they all seem to
say the same idea well yes yes it's like
so I'm just like if we're if we're gonna
say they're different like what what is
the difference okay so in regards to
each individual I can't get into nuances
of each individual so there are some
individuals who are when it comes to
marriage are explicitly marriage I think
the whole institution of marriage as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible